diese erfindung könnte den durchbruch
bedeuten und einem internationalen
forschungsteam könnte ein neu
entwickeltes material reisen zu anderen
sternen möglich machen zum beispiel zum
stern proxima centauri eine sonde würde
für die entfernung von 4,2 lichtjahren
dann nur 20 jahre brauchen
möglich machen soll das ein so genanntes
aerogele ein material das extrem mit
temperatursprünge ganz easy aushält und
somit als laser segel dienen könnte ob
und wie dann demnächst tatsächlich eine
reise zu proxima centauri möglich ist
klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann und nur dann verpasst ja nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen die
eigenschaften der sogenannten aerogele
sind außergewöhnlich die stoffe sind
ultraleicht und sehr puls kein wunder
denn das material besteht aus sehr
dünnen metall oder keramik schichten und
häufig zu mehr als 99 prozent aus luft
beziehungsweise frei im raum quasi ein
hauch von nichts und schon jetzt werden
die stoffe in der praxis eingesetzt
siliziumoxid aerogele beispielsweise in
raumanzügen aerogele dienen zudem als
dämmstoffe doch bislang sind das alles
spezialanwendungen da sich die
herstellung derzeit noch als sehr
kompliziert und aufwendig gestaltet
zudem hatten die erogene bis jetzt eine
große schwachstelle bei großen
temperaturschwankungen zerbricht das
material nämlich sehr leicht doch genau
diesem problem hat sich nun ein
internationales forschungsteam
angenommen und das äußerst erfolgreich
die neu entwickelten aerogele bestehen
zu mehr als 99 prozent aus luft oder
eben leerem raum und halten sogar sehr
schnelle temperaturwechsel von mehr als
1000 grad celsius stand und das eröffnet
uns bislang ungeahnte möglichkeiten aber
von vorne
die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen konstruierten
zunächst ein symmetrisches gerüst aus
graphen
wir haben hier ja bei klick zum science
fiction öfter über diesen wunderstoff
berichtet bei diesen atome dünnen
kohlenstoffschichten handle sich um mit
das dünnste material der welt und aber
ist es härter als diamant das
forschungsteam bottle damit
zweidimensionale schichten auf den unter
einer schutzatmosphäre aus ergon
kristalline lagen aus borne nitrit
wachsen ließ das café wurde dann bei
etwa 600 grad celsius abgetrennt so dass
nur noch das aerogel aus dem
und ried schichten in einer äußerst
symmetrische anordnung übrig blieb
dieses netzwerk sieht von der seite aus
betrachtet wie eine art spinnennetz aus
und die meta struktur begründet die
besonderen eigenschaften des neu
entwickelten euro geht statt sich bei
erwärmung auszudehnen zieht es sich
zusammen wenn das war daher mechanisch
gestreckt wird wird es in der mitte
nicht dünner sondern dicker in der
fachsprache spricht man dann von einer
negativen postsaal und einem negativen
wärme ausdehnungskoeffizienten dazu sie
anfang an einer der beteiligten forscher
unser aero gezeigt sowohl eine
herausragende mechanische als auch
thermische stabilität für super
isolatoren unter extremen bedingungen
das forschungsteam testete das aerogel
aufs äußerste
sie erhitzen es auf bis zu 1500 grad
celsius und das sind sehr kurzer zeit
schnell kühlten sie es dann ria ab und
zwar auf bis zu minus 198 grad celsius
extreme temperaturschwankungen also und
dennoch blieb die aerogele struktur
erhalten anders als gewöhnliche
keramiken die dabei zerbröseln
doch es gibt noch weitere bemerkenswerte
eigenschaften des aero gs verfügt
nämlich über eine extrem geringe dichte
eine probe des aero geht's in der größe
eines würfels wiegt gerade mal achtung
ein tausendstel gramm zudem den sich das
material ohne druck wieder in seine
ursprüngliche form zurück selbst wenn es
mit einer presse auf einen bruchteil
seiner größe zusammengedrückt wird drei
faktoren sorgen wohl dafür dass das
material so gut isoliert zum einen
bilden winzige kleine brüche in der
betriebsstruktur die wärmeleitung zudem
handle sich bei den poren wenden um
doppel wende die an eine
doppelverglasung bei fenstern erinnern
und somit gut isolieren und als weiteren
punkt ist die wärmeleitung und
feststoffe reduziert und zwar durch die
sehr geringe dichte des materials
zusammengefasst vereint das material
somit also einige sehr besondere
eigenschaften und die lassen das
forschungsteam krasse visionen
entwickeln aerogele könnten neben dafür
eine revolution in der erkundung des
weltraums sorgen da das material so gut
isoliert könnte es als
hitzeschutzkacheln von raumtransporter
eingesetzt werden denn die luft reibung
beim wiedereintritt in die erdatmosphäre
sorgt für extreme temperaturen und auch
bei einer drehung im erdnahen orbit muss
eine sonde ein temperaturwechsel von
mehreren hundert grad überstehen können
laut dem forschungsteam könnte das
aerogel als material für ein laser säge
die laserstrahlen könnten dann das sehr
leichte material auf rund 20 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit bringen 20 jahre
würde die reise zum 4,2 lichtjahre
entfernten stern proxima centauri den
berechnungen zufolge dauern
doch nicht nur das das neu entwickelte
euro geht könnte auch im automobilbau
eingesetzt werden
seine starken isolations eigenschaften
könnten beispielsweise autobahn teile
von vor den hohen temperaturen schutz
wie etwa von katalysatoren ausgehen und
auch in wasserstoff autos könnte sich
das material als nützlich erweisen denn
es könnte die reaktion in der
brennstoffzelle als katalysator genauso
gut beschleunigen wie das derzeit
eingesetzte kostspielige platin eine
große herausforderung in
brennstoffzellen fahrzeugen die damit
endlich gelöst wäre ein problem dabei
ist bislang noch der komplizierte
herstellungsprozess um das aerogel auf
masse zu produzieren müsste noch ein
geeignetes verfahren entwickelt werden
doch das forschungsteam ist optimistisch
dazu du an
derzeit arbeiten wir außerdem an extrem
leicht nach euro gehen die sogar noch
robuster flexibler und hitzebeständiger
werden könnten
wow das ist ja dann wirklich was aus
diesem wirklich extrem material alles
hergestellt werden kann
es kann soviel revolutionieren wie es
zum beispiel die supraleitung gemacht
hat und immer noch macht plötzlich sind
dinge denke die wir bisher für unmöglich
gehalten haben nano technologien wie wir
die grundbausteine unserer welt
verändern können unbedingt hier
draufklicken da gibt es von cedric von
kana doktor watson einen noch umfassend
über blick über das thema also
draufklicken ansehen abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran